but the thing that is happening is that
as they bring this workforce with them
no one is talking to them saying don't
screw it up when you move to this new
place okay i gotta leave california
silicon valley because this place sucks
uh and so they end up coming here and
they want to vote the same way now there
are individuals that are leaving
california illinois new york and new
jersey for all the right reasons but
when you have this mass transplant
and i call it the locust effect i mean
people go to the you know very good
thriving fertile grounds like california
used to be and they chew it up and
destroy it and then they look and see
where else they can go
where do you think
some of the say disaffected liberals
maybe
libertarians
like the wider group right now that i
think i've been saying for a while it's
sort of woke versus everybody and and
it's our job it's our job as everybody
to kind of figure out how we can work
together how we can disagree and agree
to disagree etc how do you think that
thing can work
or do you think that thing can work
i do think it can work it has to be
based upon individual rights freedoms
and liberties and you know i'll give you
a case in point just recently i was up
in new york city uh and you know went
out to get something to eat after you
know a fox interview and everything and
i walked into this diner and guy asked
me where's your covet uh shot card and i
said i don't have a covert shot card i'm
visiting here from texas he said well
you can't eat here
i think that's going to be the thing
that you dice people because i remember
my mother and father once upon a time
they were told that they could eat in
certain places because their skin color
but now we've been told we can't eat in
certain places because someone has
decided that we have to get this thing
injected into our bodies and i really
believe that when people start to hear
that they no longer have control over
their own bodies that's going to be a
rallying cry just the same as you've
seen when
terry mcauliffe stands up in a debate
and says parents don't have a right to
decide what their children are being
taught oh man you brought out people in
virginia that would have never cared
about a virginia gubernatorial race and
so a year ago joe biden wins virginia by
11 and 12 points a year later they lose
virginia by two or three points so i
think that that's the shift that we see
happening when you start to touch
people's individual rights freedom and
liberty when you start to reach inside
their homes or affect their bodies then
people are going to wake up to this yeah
it used to be my body my choice not not
so much for them anymore but you
mentioned two to three points speaking
of two to three points the last
senatorial campaign in texas uh ted cruz
only beat beto by
about three points i think it was two
and a half if i'm not mistaken it was a
lot closer yeah it was a lot closer than
people thought what does that tell you
about what's happening in texas is is
austin getting weird you know filtering
throughout the state is that what's
happening
well i think that the the beta effect
that happened in
2018 was that he was a new person and
and the media built this aura around him
and there was a lot of angst and anxiety
against senator cruz but now the the
cat's out the bag and we know who this
mr o'rourke is and what he stands for
and he's completely antithetical to
texas principles and values but when you
look at what is happening in texas when
you look at what is happening in many
red states
california used to be a red state i mean
this was the state that gave us richard
nixon and ronald reagan what is
happening in texas is that we have had
governors going to blue states and
saying why don't you pick up and move
your business or your corporation here
uh because we have better policies and
you can economically thrive but the
thing that is happening is that as they
bring this workforce with them no one is
talking to them saying don't screw it up
when you move to this new place okay i
gotta leave california silicon valley
because this place sucks uh and so they
end up coming here and they want to vote
the same way now there are individuals
that are leaving california illinois new
york and new jersey for all the right
reasons but when you have this mass
transplant
and i call it the locust effect i mean
people go to the you know very good
thriving fertile grounds like california
used to be and they chew it up and
destroy it and then they look and see
where else they can go but i will tell
you hats off to elon musk because
earlier in november eli must put out a
tweet to the people there in austin
saying admonishing them saying don't let
austin become the new san francisco
because the people in austin since they
defunded the police got all woke and
everything like that they've seen a 66
percent increase in violent crime 71
percent increase in homicide the
homeless situation there is absolutely
disgusting and appalling people don't go
downtown in austin at night but yet they
still voted down a proposition to refund
the police and so i think that's at the
core something that's going to to change
because all of a sudden when people
realize that their personal safety and
security is at risk
they'll back away from this
can you get those people though to
change i get that you might be able to
get the true texan that's been there you
know for a lifetime to go okay we really
gotta vote the right way but the ones
that come from silicon valley it takes
sort of a little smacking around for
them to realize that they're leaving the
thing that they voted for
it does and i think it's another thing
we have to do is teach them about you
know the history of texas or you know
the history of georgia or tennessee and
why they're successful and you know
understand that texas is the only state
in the union that fought for one it's
independence by itself uh but i think
the other thing that we have to do
without a doubt is understand that you
know find out where those strong
crossing points like you and i just
discussed well you get the 60 to 65
percent because i don't i think is that
35 to 40 percent you're probably just
not going to get through to them but
let's go after the people that
understand and that's why we had such
success uh when i was the chairman of
the party going down into the rio grande
valley and we told the people in the
hispanic community who had never seen a
republican party chairman in the rio
grande valley previous to that your
principles and values are our principles
and values you know it wasn't about the
outreach it was about the engagement
outreach means you show up in a black
history month hispanic american heritage
month and then people never see you
again until a couple of months before an
election but when you're there all the
time 24 7 365 talking about those common
points that that you can expand upon
then people will rally to your cause and
again i think that this is more of a
philosophical ideological uh cultural uh
basis that we have to approach things
and not just about political parties
anymore so i i hate to do the identity
politics thing obviously and i know you
don't want to do it either but it exists
whether we talk about it or not
that's their their battleground that's
what they've got as you know i
campaigned with larry elder who's a good
friend of mine i saw what the machine
did to him for joe biden to show up here
the day before the election refused to
say larry's name call him a trump clone
a guy who grew up in south central l.a
son of a janitor i mean it's so
extraordinarily evil the stuff that
gavin newsom did the evil ads that reed
hastings from netflix put out about
larry blackface of white supremacy
according to l.a times you you know all
the stuff
there's obviously going to be a version
of that that's going to come after you
are you know you've been through the
game before but are you are you ready
for it in a gubernatorial thing which is
different than a congressional race and
you know being a talking head on fox et
cetera
well absolutely and one of the things
about being here in the state of texas
the republican party of texas was
founded on independence day of 1867 by
150 black men in houston texas uh one of
the early chairman was norris rykuni you
think about juneteenth and you think
about how recently they just dedicated a
statue to a man who was a former slave
state senator matthew gaines who was
instrumental in establishing texas a m
university and prairie view a m
university and he's buried there at
texas a m university guess who's also
buried there on the campus of texas a m
you know president george h.w bush and
his wife and so when you talk about
these things and you use history to
illuminate people and you talk about the
real party of systemic racism has been
the democrat party i often tell folks
there are two ways that you can enslave
people one is that you work them for no
pay and the other is that you pay them
for no work and tell me which party has
done that in the history of the united
states of america so i think that as
long as you stand strong and you always
go on the offense not on the defense uh
you put them back on their heels you
know
all this talk about white supremacy and
racism i have yet to see anyone on the
left speak out against margaret sanger
margaret sanger you know created planned
parenthood for one reason because she
believed that blacks were undesirables
and human weeds and yet we see 71 to 73
percent of planned parenthood clinics
and minority communities so as long as
we are the aggressor as long as we are
pinning them on their heels we don't let
them define the narrative and i think
that's the thing that the military
taught me and that's how we're going to
make sure that we don't allow them to
dictate and define who i am if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification bell